bonsoir voici les titres de ce journal
ouverture à paris devant la cour
d'assises du procès de florence rey
accusés de meurtres et de tentatives de
meurtres multiples notamment contre des
policiers commis en octobre 94 cours de
vincennes à paris
les adhérents de l'udf ont choisi
françois bayrou pour nouveau président
successeur de françois léotard questions
sur l'avenir de l'udf monsieur françois
bayrou est notre invité l'organisation
séparatiste basque eta annonce une trève
illimitée et unilatérales pour la
première fois dans son histoire
espoir et prudence parmi les réactions
c'est officiel yannick noah quitte ses
fonctions de capitaine des équipes de
france de tennis leconte et forget parmi
les postulants théâtre le voyage des
comédiens s'est installé pour plus de
trois mois dans le centre de la france
pour le plaisir des habitants de petites
villes ou villages au tout début de cet
après midi la cour d'assises de paris
entre est en séance puis les jurés
étaient tirés au sort magistrats et
jurés devront juger florence rey
aujourd'hui âgé de 23 ans accusé de
quatre meurtres et de multiples
tentatives de meurtres commis au mois
d'octobre 94 circonstance aggravante des
policiers ont été tués mais l'auteur
présumé de la fusillade compagnon
florence rey et audry maupin n'est plus
là il est mort lors de cette équipée
sanglante reportage dominique verdeilhan
florence rey a longtemps hésité mais
pour offrir des lunes nouvelles images
elle a accepté d'être filmés
photographiés dans le box des assises
florence rey depuis quatre ans était
avant tout cette photo prise par les
policiers le soir de son arrestation un
regard dur une égratignure
les bras croisés
la limite de la provocation aujourd'hui
c'est un autre visage celui d'une
adolescente de 23 ans à la silhouette
frêle ses avocats sont catégoriques
florence rey a changé dans la salle
d'audience la tension est extrême
les familles des victimes d'exclure à
leur tour ce visage juvénile et au
détour d'un plan on aperçoit florence
rey essuyant avec ses manches quelques
là dans une vitrine les pièces à
conviction nous ramène à la triste
réalité du dossier des fusils à pompe
des revolver des munitions un arsenal
que l'on découvre rarement chez deux
adolescents de 19 et 23 ans
florence rey et son compagnon audry mots
le 4 octobre 94 les deux jeunes gens
attaquent la préfourrière de pantin ils
braquent les armes des punitions pour
fuir ils prennent en otage un chauffeur
de taxi et son passager dans le taxi je
lui donnais 17 18 ans a pas plus voyez
est vraiment elle agissait avec une
maîtrise qui me fait frémir
paniqué le chauffeur de taxi percute
volontairement une voiture de police
place de la nation la fusillade qui s'en
suivra fait trois morts deux policiers
et le chauffeur de taxi nouvelles fuites
nouvelle prise d'otage nouvelle
fusillade un troisième policier tué
blessé
audry maupin 17 dans la nuit florence
rey se retrouve seul face aux enquêteurs
dans leur squat de nanterre on
découvrira des catalogues d'armes des
tracts révolutionnaire et la fiche du
film urnes et aujourd'hui les victimes
attendent de florence rey des
explications
elle a été effectivement plus que
taisante au cours de l'instruction et
les parties civiles les victimes
attendent encore une fois que la vérité
soit dite et que la justice soit faite
dans les couloirs du palais de justice
deux silhouettes les parents de florence
rey comme les victimes ils attendent une
réponse à la question pourquoi dominique
veillon comme tout le monde la presse
puis toulon qui était là il y avait une
sorte de curiosité malsaine on voulait
voir à quoi florence rey ressembler
c'est bien ça on voulait voir mais on
voulait surtout entendre et c'est le
second choc de cet après-midi parce que
face à ses juges face à ces victimes
florence rey est enfin sorti de son
silence
elle s'est exprimée certes d'une voix
fluette elle cherche ses mots c'est une
jeune fille en apparence timide ce n'est
en rien en tout cas la bonnie de bonnie
and clyde que l'on a présenté souvent
dans la presse et ses premiers mots vont
aux familles de victimes je suis désolé
leur dit-elle cela a été un enchaînement
effroyable
je comprends votre douleur je sais ce
que c'est que de perdre un ami un proche
j'aurais aimé que cela n'arrive jamais
et puis florence rey parle de cette nuit
tragique avec les mots d'une passion
inachevé je n'avais pas d'autre solution
que de suivre audry cela me fait peur la
rapidité avec laquelle on peut en
arriver là
florence rey assume son rôle tout en
rappelant que si elle a tiré
elle a tué personne on a donc le
sentiment ce soir d'assister à un procès
de plusieurs vies gâchées celle des
victimes bien sûr celle d'audry maupin
mais aussi celle de florence rey parce
que ces 25 minutes d'enfer
ils feront courir ce soir la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité
merci de mini dans le secteur financier
l'annoncent par le crédit lyonnais de
bénéfices en baisse suite à des
provisions pour la russie et l'asie ne
fait que renforcer des perspectives
rapide de privatisation le crédit
lyonnais est apparemment une bonne
affaire puisque les candidats se
bousculent le président du crédit
lyonnais monsieur peyrelevade semble
même très satisfait
reportage jean-paul chapelle andré
germain le patron du crédit lyonnais a
retrouvé le sourire y annonce
aujourd'hui un chiffre d'affaires
os oublier le scandale du siècle à la
veille de la privatisation
les candidats se bousculent pour entrer
dans le capital de la banque
d'abord son concurrent et voisin la bnp
mais aussi la société générale paribas
axa et même alliance
le géant allemand de l'assurance je ne
pense pas qu'il soit question
aujourd'hui que le crédit lyonnais
aïe dans des mains allemandes je ne
pense pas d'ailleurs qu'il soit question
que le crayonné soit racheté par une
institution quelle qu'elle soit
le crédit lyonnais d'aujourd'hui n'a
rien à voir avec celui des années 80 sa
folie des grandeurs ces infractions et
ces délits ont déjà coûté 100 milliards
de francs à l'état 3000 francs par foyer
contribuables on a séparé la mauvaise
banque de la bonne banque et c'est la
bonne qui aiguise aujourd'hui toutes les
convoitises
ils peuvent le fait de dieu ne devienne
pas un concurrent et que donc ce n'est
pas une autre banque concurrente qui en
devienne l'actionnaire de contrôle ou un
assureur en général dix ans un
concurrent le gouvernement devrait faire
connaître bientôt les modalités de cette
privatisation mais la chute de la bourse
et la crise financière diminue
énormément la valeur du crédit lyonnais
nouvelle rechute collectif des cotations
sur les places boursières
internationales y compris à wall street
cet après midi je suis sans doute dû à
l'absence de bonnes perspectives
économiques mondiales à paris la bourse
a perdu 5 points 47 avec une baisse
spectaculaire pour alcatel de plus de
38% il ya des explications ce soir
gérard klein
il faut d'abord dire que jamais une
action cotée au cac 40 de la bourse de
paris n'avait connu une telle chute -38%
vous l'avais dit en une journée après
avoir été réservé huit fois à la baisse
soit bilan une perte de 71 milliards de
francs de capitalisation d'une journée à
l'origine une petite phrase du pdg
d'alcatel ce matin dans la conférence de
presse de présentation des résultats
semestriels de son entreprise
ceux-ci n'atteindront pas cette année at
il dit le niveau prévu du fait d'une
baisse brutale du marché des
télécommunications en europe en asie en
europe en asie du sud-est et en russie
alors rien de catastrophique de prime
abord des bénéfices réduit de moitié par
rapport à ce qui était attendu mais cela
a fait l'effet d'une douche
attachez les financiers qui s'était
beaucoup engagé dans ce secteur dans le
sillage d'ailleurs d'autres valeurs
vedettes de la bourse travaillant dans
l'électronique comme schneider alstom ou
lagardère ont perdu plus de 10%
la bourse de paris a finalement
abandonné 5 et 10% son plus fort recul
depuis août 1991
cette mauvaise nouvelle s'ajoute à une
autre l'absence de baisse des taux
d'intérêt des etats-unis qui auraient pu
soutenir l'activité alors en résumé une
crise qui persiste en russie en asie les
premières conséquences sur les comptes
des grandes entreprises
l'inaction des autorités monétaires
vient de quoi ébranler la confiance des
boursiers durablement c'est toute la
question dans les prochains jours vont
dire merci puis j'ajoute que le
ministère de l'économie vient de faire
savoir que chargé de la rsp de la
concurrence il refuse son autorisation
au rachat par coca cola de la société
origin a les conditions de respect
d'équité de concurrence n'étant pas
réunies
le groupe américain toys le numéro un
mondial de la distribution de jouets
annonce la fermeture de 50 de ses
magasins principalement implanté en
europe il dire actuellement 44 magasins
toys en france et 1230 employés on ne
connaît pas encore le détail de ces
fermetures annoncées l'année dernière à
l'issue du vote de quelques 18 mille
adhérents l'union pour la démocratie
française a connu une passation de
pouvoir françois léotard a transmis la
présidence de ce mouvement à françois
bayrou
mais les forces de l'idf sont éparpillés
c'est bien là le principal challenge du
nouveau président enquête carole comme
1978 valéry giscard d'estaing alors
président de la république décide de
mettre en place une machine de guerre
électorale pour contrer le rpr de
jacques chirac le 1er février plusieurs
formations de droite et non gaullistes
se regroupent au sein de l'union pour la
démocratie française
c'est jean lecanuet un démocrate
chrétien qui en prend la présidence
dix ans plus tard françois mitterrand
est réélu président de la république et
valéry giscard d'estaing décide de
prendre la présidence de l'udf
mais il ne parviendra pas à contenir les
dissensions et les querelles de
personnes lors de l'élection
présidentielle de 95 l'udf se déchire au
grand jour
les un soutien d'edouard balladur tandis
que d'autres comme alain madelin
s'engage derrière jacques chirac
un an plus tard valéry giscard d'estaing
est poussé vers la sortie
c'est françois léotard qui n'en portent
sur un amas demain pour la présidence de
l'udf
mais la défaite de la droite aux
législatives de 97 et surtout les
élections régionales de mars dernier
provoque une nouvelle crise en mai alain
madelin et son parti démocratie libérale
décide de quitter l'udf françois bayrou
prend donc aujourd'hui la présidence
d'une df affaibli opposé de quatre
formations et d'un courant politique
les centristes de force démocrate déjà
présidé par françois bayrou
quarante-huit députés le pdf présidé par
hervé de charette de député les
adhérents directs de l'udf dirigé par
pierre-andré geiser sept députés le
parti radical présidé par thierry
cornillet trois députés enfin le prix un
courant créé par des libéraux comme
gilles de robien qui n'ont pas voulu
suivre alain madelin et ont choisi de
rester à l'udf lui députés
cinq familles pour une nouvelle df que
françois bayrou se dit résolu à unifier
même s'il le sait la tâche sera pour le
moins difficile ça vaille arrogance
phare comment vous allez faire pour
revenir tout ça coûte et on a vécu
suffisamment de difficultés depuis
plusieurs mois pour que désormais on
voit bien que la volonté unanime de tous
ceux qui croient l'opposition qui
voudraient lui apporter son soutien ou
qui espèrent en elle c'est que désormais
on se rassemble et c'est tout le sens de
mon élection petit lièvre c'est mal
parti parce que déjà pour la présidence
du sénat y ait une bagarre entre le rpr
monsieur poncelet et monsieur monory que
vous soutenez que soutien apparemment
monsieur chirac très bien les gens g
j'ai vu le président de la république
cet après midi et je lui ai dit il m'a
dit que il était inimaginable en ce
moment connaît à nouveau des divisions
au sénat après en avoir eu le temps
étant l'alliance je suis impliqué je
suis sûr j'ai confiance que tout le
monde va réfléchir à la responsabilité
qui est la nôtre en ce moment en ce
moment il ya un mot de la vente était
quand même parce que vous avez des
rénovateurs en 89 11 a demandé d'autres
fédérer la nébuleuse udf pendant un
moment puis là vous remplit quéau
au travail vous croyez que c'est encore
joie qu'on peut encore fait un pardon
selon centriste non seulement je le
crois mais j'en suis sûr comme vous
dites gr je crois à cette idée depuis
longtemps et j'ai beaucoup fait pour
essayer de la faire d'être je crois que
c'est le monde que c'est le moment
aujourd'hui mon idée celui des 10 car
elle est simple depuis le début cette
famille politique elle peut peser de
manière vraiment très importante sur le
destin de la france parce que c'est là
probablement qu est le point d équilibre
de la vie politique française mais elle
ne pèsera que chez les réunit
de la même manière que l'opposition dans
son dans son ensemble l'opposition dans
une démocratie c'est une responsabilité
très importante c'est sa porte l'espoir
mais vous êtes d'accord avec ma cantine
après le drame est intéressant non
seulement elle est absente ou elle n'est
pas à la hauteur de sa tâche et ce qui
s'est passé hier pour nous c'est le
premier pas de la reconstruction
une reconstruction qui est simple qui
portent des noms on rassemble on tend la
main
on regroupe tout ce qui doit l'être pour
que de nouveau les français et est
confiant c'est super ouzou dans votre
d'un raz-de-marée vous pensez vous irait
jusqu'à un jour la fusion d'un seul et
même grands partis comme en allemagne où
il ya et chrétiens-démocrates et
sociaux-démocrates est ce que un jour la
france orale semaine bipartisme et
choisir je crois que l'opposition est
plurielle mais pour autant elle doit pas
être explosé elle pluriel parce que vous
voyez bien il ya des sensibilités d'une
plus européenne c'est la nôtre l'autre
plus nationale c'est celle du rpr et il
est légitime que ses deux sensibilités
j'allais dire ces deux manières de faire
de la politique
s'exprime elles ont toutes les deux leur
place pour autant elles doivent
travailler ensemble et si mon élection à
un sens c'est précisément que nous
allons nous regrouper à l'intérieur pour
nous rassembler avec nos alliés
alors concrètement liste unique pour les
élections européennes l'année prochaine
monsieur seguin repoussent à plus tard
dans son interview au figaro il ay la
raison de repousser après la réflexion
qui va être celle de son mouvement
pour moi c'est très simple dès l'instant
que nous aurons une plateforme
européenne commune dans ses grandes
lignes
dès cet instant là il faudra construire
la liste la plus large possible parce
que le drame c'est que les français ne
pèse pas assez haut
strasbourg parlement européen n'occupe
pas ils n'ont pas l'influencent qu'il
devrait avoir
et ils ne l'auront que s'ils sont
nombreux et c'est notre c'est évidemment
le cas de ceux de l'opposition qui sont
éclatés un des gros arme ultime question
à laquelle vous venez vite et jamais
vous avez une position très claire à
l'égard du front national vous êtes prêt
exclure tout ce qui est du ds n'aurait
pas la même que j'ai une position très
claire pour une raison simple je
souhaite qu'on n'en parle plus je ne
sais pas si nous avons complètement vous
rendez compte
vous êtes d'accord avec moi concrètement
ça toutes les clarifications sont faites
chez nous et elles seront faites
quiconque et je repars en fait hamas ont
fait augmenter relève
je crois que tout le monde devra y venir
pour autant c'est pas si vous vous
rendez compte du désespoir qui est celui
des de ceux qui croient à l'opposition
voudrait y croire
un entendre le leader de l'opposition
s'exprimer que sur ce seul sujet nous
nous avons fait le choix de la clarté
précisément pour que notre position soit
connu insoupçonnable et qu'on en parle
plus parce qu'autrement on fait de la
pub à l'extrême droite
faire de la publicité à l'extrême droite
ça la serre où se serrent la gauche 17
nous certaine ça vous sert pas merci
merci à lui pour les élections
européennes de l'année prochaine arrête
laguiller alain krivine ont décidé de
faire liste commune ensemble
lutte ouvrière et la ligue communiste
révolutionnaire animeront une liste dite
gauche radicale anticapitaliste
féministe et écologiste
le projet de pacte civil de solidarité
le pacs selon l'église catholique est
une loi inutile et dangereuse qui
fragilise le mariage et menace la
cohérence de la société réponse de
madame guigou à ce communiqué du conseil
permanent l'épiscopat français
c'est très bien qu'il y est un débat
mais ce que nous voulons c'est donner
une sécurité juridique pour traiter de
situations humainement insupportable le
débat c'est au parlement à partir du 9
octobre et pendant quatre jours en
espagne l'organisation indépendantiste
basque eta a annoncé hier soir une trêve
illimitée est unilatéral c'est la
première fois depuis trente ans de lutte
armée il ya eu cependant plusieurs
trêves après certains attentats mais
cette fois au pays basque espagnol
on souhaite que cette décision de letea
soit prise au sérieux à madrid le
gouvernement monsieur asnar exprime son
scepticisme
comment taire leurs ambitions une trêve
unilatérale et illimitée des opérations
militaires la phrase est brève
noyer dans un long communiqué de 17
pages mais c'est elle que tout le monde
retient une trève illimitée annoncée par
ota
la dernière grande organisation
clandestine en europe qui mène une lutte
armée contre un gouvernement européen
une trève illimitée la première dans
l'histoire de thé à mes accueilli quand
même avec prudence voire scepticisme par
le gouvernement espagnol
le t1 doit savoir que sa crédibilité
dépend d'elle il faut des actes et pas
seulement des déclarations c'était le tl
letea seul de nous prouver qu'elle veut
la paix
quarante ans de lutte pour
l'indépendance du pays basque 769
assassinats des dizaines d'enlèvements
et de très nombreux attentats l'histoire
de thé à et sanglantes depuis plusieurs
années les polices espagnole et
française lui porte des coups sérieux
mais c'est le meurtre d'un conseiller
municipal basque miguel angel blanco
il y a un an qu'il y ensemble des partis
politiques espagnols qu'on protège le
lendemain de ce meurtre aux pays-bas ce
que même des dizaines de milliers de
personnes descendront dans la rue pour
demander la fin de la violence
comme leur gouvernement les espagnols
les basques sont donc content mais
sceptique devant l' annonce de cette
trêve
il ya déjà eu des preuves de letea dans
le passé mais c'était des mensonges
cette fois avec l'exemple de l'irlande
on peut y croire moi j'habite ici et je
suis calculs politiques ou envie de paix
comme l'immense majorité des basques en
annonçant cette trêve eta dont 600
membres sont en prison demande peut-être
pour la première fois de véritables
négociations israël le premier ministre
netanyahou vient d'encourager des colons
extrémistes juifs à construire 1 600
nouveaux logements cette décision du
gouvernement israélien a été annoncée
juste après la fin de la mission au
proche-orient du médiateur américain
monsieur dennis ross charles enderlin
depuis jérusalem est ce que vous avez le
sentiment que désormais on est presque à
un point de non retour avec les accords
de paix rédigé à oslo comme date butoir
en 99 on n'ira pas on ira jamais jusqu'à
ces accords de paix oui en effet
l'initiative américaine semble faire
long feu après son dernier entretien
avec yasser arafat hier soir le
médiateur américain dennis ross a
déclaré qu'il avait réglé quelques
problèmes mais que des difficultés très
importantes subsistent notamment
l'absence de confiance entre les parties
surtout entre peut-être aussi entre lui
même et les palestiniens qui l'ont
critiqué à plusieurs reprises et
monsieur rentre aujourd'hui a passé sa
journée à visiter gasol 17 très rare il
a rencontré des familles de détenus
palestiniens en israël mais en fait la
direction palestinienne se prépare déjà
à l'après oslo selon les accords les
négociations israélo palestiniennes
doivent aboutir avant le 4 mai 1999 il
ya serrar a fait annoncer qu'à cette
date il proclamera quoi qu'il arrive
l'indépendance de son état les
israéliens menacent de prendre dans ce
cas des mesures unilatérales très durs
contre l'autorité palestinienne qui elle
prévoit le pire
déjà par exemple les hôpitaux
palestiniens de cisjordanie et gaza ont
reçu l'ordre dans magazine et du
matériel d'urgence
si charles pour les responsables
politiques l'un des dossiers majeurs
dans cette région demeure depuis des
dizaines d'années celui de l'eau mais
les conditions climatiques actuelles
agra la situation des populations
palestiniennes installées soit en
jordanie soit à gaz un reportage charles
enderlin c'est la pénurie d'eau la plus
grave que connaît la jordanie depuis des
années ce barrage dans la vallée du
jourdain est complètement secs et les
canaux d'irrigation charrie un liquide
boue et l'eau diable amman les habitants
ont découvert il ya trois mois que le
peu d'eau livré par la municipalité
était gravement pollués nabil qui est
chimiste installé chez lui un filtre
mais sans grand succès même filtré
boulnois un mauvais goût elle laisse un
dépôt brin regarder au fond de ce
récipient je suis très inquiète
j'ai peur que mes enfants attrapent
quelque chose même lorsqu'il se brosse
les dents pour remplir ses réservoirs
sur le toit nabil est obligé d'acheter
de l'eau apportée par camion citerne et
paye quatre fois le prix normal
la population accuse le gouvernement
d'incapacité israël d'avoir fourni à la
jordanie de l'eau polluée
si nous ne trouvons pas rapidement une
solution par une coopération régionale
ce sera la pénurie d'eau qui déterminera
notre santé notre mode de vie notre
développement futur
jean la côte méditerranéenne à gaza la
situation est tout aussi sérieuse un
million de palestiniens y vivent sur 200
kilomètres carrés ils ont le taux de
croissance démographique le plus élevé
au monde
51 % de la population a moins de 15 ans
et les réserves d'eau si ici une petite
station de dessalement fournit de l'eau
potable car celle du robinet lorsqu'il y
en a et celle des mères c'est la course
bien percer depuis plusieurs besoins des
français
à un moment il y aura la sécheresse n'y
a pas que la sécheresse est le plus gros
problème c'est la pollution des pluies
et par contre accéléré parce qu'il n'ya
pas de ses rouages
il n'y a pas de retraitement des eaux et
de collections de l'écomusée
il faudrait donc construire de grandes
usines de dessalement de l'eau de mer
mais c'est une utopie pour les
palestiniens et à gaza les responsables
craignent une révolte de l'autre s'il
est seulement un problème de travail par
les gens ici il ya des gens qui ont
travaillé depuis près de cinq ans mais
non pas attendre cinq jours sans eau
les responsables israéliens affirment
qu'ils tiennent tous leurs engagements
fournissent à la jordanie et aux
palestiniens la quantité et la qualité
d'eau promises
nous utilisons toutes les réserves à
notre disposition il est faux de dire
que nous avons des réserves kasha en
d'autres termes la pénurie d'eau conduit
tout droit le proche-orient à une crise
majeure
pour l'éviter il faudrait un programme
de développement massif une coopération
régionale possible uniquement dans le
cadre de la véritable processus de paix
le traité international d'interdiction
des mines antipersonnel entre dans le
droit international
officiellement il fallait pour cela que
40 pays ratifient la convention la chine
et les états unis n'ont pas fait en
revanche c'est le burkina faso qui par
son adhésion permet de rendre
obligatoire l'interdiction des mines
antipersonnel en france quinze jours
après la rentrée scolaire dans les
lycées le syndicat national des
enseignants du second degré le snes fsu
confirme son mot d'ordre de grève pour
le 24 septembre et ce malgré de
nombreuses réunions au ministère
principal point de désaccord la
rémunération des heures supplémentaires
parmi les changements de cette rentrée
scolaire aux renseignements nous avons
choisi de nous intéresser à la
restauration dans les écoles les
collèges et les lycées 7 millions de
jeunes sont concernés
vous avez constaté une certaine
désaffection des cantines à présent de
nouvelles formules sont proposées aux
scolaires
voyez le reportage de stéphane haumant
et claude bernier
ton mon jambon l'inventer à l'heure de
la cantine les adolescents préfèrent
varier le menu 22 francs le repas
étudiants c'est exactement le même prix
qu'un ticket à la demi-pension voisine
le sait plus rapide plus convivial et la
cantine a vraiment trop mauvaise
réputation
on a dit ça il vous fait parce que c'est
plus cher
génial mauvaise qualité par mon moins
bonne qualité qu'ici à toxic à sion est
dès lors les nantais pas intoxication
alimentaire dont on attend forcément le
temps rien qu'aux abords immédiats de
cet établissement parisien six
brasseries de restaurants classiques de
chinois une pizzeria de boulangerie et 2
sandwicherie au réfectoire le soient
c'est plutôt pizza puce pâtes ou pat tu
seras goût alors ici à evry on a trouvé
la parade à la fuite des lycéens une
cafétéria new look au sein de
l'établissement
couleur café un comptoir du choix des
formules plats chauds à 27 francs et ça
marche
elle n'a qu'à peine à peine une
trentaine varrod
des lycéens et si combien 400 pour la
société de restauration collective qui a
installé cinq de ses fast-food scolaire
en france il reste maintenant à rajeunir
les bons vieux réfectoire et ça c'est
une autre affaire fera que la vieille
cantine c'était je prends mon entrée je
prends mon plat sur une ligne toute
droite
l'idée c'est de se dire j'ai une
possibilité faut je prends des vitamines
franc je crois d'un plat chaud fofana
laitages et à partir de ça je peux
composer mon plateau librement pour
l'instant on en est loin les flat
plébiscités sont toujours les mêmes
steaks frites et couscous selon une
étude presque la moitié des repas reste
dans l'assiette problèmes de qualité
la cantine est une obligation avant
d'être un plaisir aux entretiens
médicaux de bichat à paris ce sont des
problèmes de voix qui ont été abordés
par les médecins des voix éraillée cas
ces héros qu'il faut réparer souvent il
suffit d'un examen puis d'une
intervention chirurgicale et d'une
rééducation pour retrouver sa voie et
c'est essentiel pour ceux qui en usent
parfois très fortement au portage benoît
thévenet et rémy poissonnier ses hommes
font un métier à risque
ils crient pour se faire entendre et les
occasions de se casser la voix ne manque
pas en room en extinction de voix
les deux cordes vocales s'altère
progressivement alain roubian avait lui
un problème chronique il animait des
centres de vacances
résultat sur une de ses cordes vocales
s'était développé un polype une petite
excroissance sa voix trop souvent forcés
était devenu rocailleuse une petite
opération a permis d'enlever ce polype
depuis on a fait de la rééducation parce
que le polype est en général la
conséquence de plusieurs facteurs mais
essentiellement du forçage vocale dont
on travaille à faire disparaître sans
forçage il a une profession on parle
beaucoup
donc on a besoin de mettre en place une
technique est assez proche de celle des
comédiens et chanteurs d'ailleurs le
polype peut être une simple gêne mais il
peut devenir plus dangereux sous l'effet
d'ennemis bien connu l'alcool provoque
une congestion début que ge notamment au
niveau du larynx et du pharynx le tabac
provoque une irritation des voies
respiratoires
s'il ya le larynx que plus bas le poumon
le forçage vocal provoque une irritation
de cette muqueuse qui n'arrivent pas à
glisser sur un muscle tendu donc trois
causes qui vont hériter le larynx et qui
peuvent aboutir à des pathologies
chroniques à de la laryngite chronique
et pourquoi pas au cancer aux péris
depuis six mois
alain prend quand quelques précautions
ne pas trop tirer sur sa voie et
s'abstenir de fumer
maintenant dès la première prise de
parole dès le premier contact chiudi bhl
je me fais beaucoup plus à l'aise alain
roubian a même pu changer de voie
professionnelle
il est désormais commercial son
employeur a jugé le son de sa voix
enfin attractif le préfet du département
de l'isère vient de confirmer
aujourd'hui le passage de plusieurs
loups cet été dans le département des
analyses génétiques ont été pratiqué et
selon le préfet plus de 200 moutons
brebis et agneaux ont été blessées ou
bien ont disparu en raison de la
présente c'est lui cette semaine les
éleveurs de retour de transhumance ne
cachaient pas leur inquiétude devant ces
massacres d'une partie de l'entrepôt
mais les loups ont des défenseurs
reportage en isère benoît gallerey
philippe évêques
essayez le troupeau de jean pierre
jouffret déjà de retour dans la valise
bien avant la date prévue
ça l'était pour le berger là-haut dans
l'alpage il a perdu 89 brebis la plupart
égorgé l'année prochaine mais je
resterai pas cinq jours comme j'ai fait
la même quoi je vais pas vous faire
égorger une grosse vie de tous les jours
sans compter les dégâts qui à mon
troupeau
vous voyez dans l'état que le sony
bloggie nous sommes passé cinq jours en
montagne en le dessin de comme le saumon
tirs je n'ai pas pris un gramme tous les
jours tous les jours des attaques des
attaques répétées qui s'était en isère
ont fait 205 victimes contre 80 l'année
dernière sur place les gardes fédéraux
ont prélevé des excréments et des poils
grâce aux analyses génétiques
les scientifiques ont pu attribuer huit
de ces attaques ou louent les bergers
s'en doutait c'est désormais une
certitude et pour eux
l'administration doit choisir faut
qu'ils aient le courage de vous dire
s'il moudong doit quitter la montagne et
laisser la place aux prédateurs
parce que on sait très bien que tous
appellent écoles arabes la fontaine
loubinoux everio on sait très bien que
le mouton peut pas cohabiter avec le
loup le préfet de l'isère qui gère
personnellement ce dossier sensible
promet aux éleveurs qu'ils seront
indemnisés tout en rappelant que le loup
est un animal protégé
on sait maintenant que le grand canidé
est venue d'italie
il est de retour dans l'ensemble les
alpes du nord et pour ses défenseurs il
faut en terminer avec la légende
contrairement à certaines légendes n'a
pas été agressif dès qu'on dit bon il y
en a certains midis loups les loups et
le loup et je pense que la partie la
faune française on se doit au patrimoine
futur dans la capacité de garder avec
nous des mesures de prévention sont à
l'étude comme le dressage de chiens de
protection
il y à peine un siècle les loups ont été
chassés et j'estime et dans les alpes
aujourd'hui la cohabitation est
inévitable sport tennis yannick noah
quittera bien ses fonctions de capitaine
d équipe de france il en a informé
officiellement la fédération française
yannick noah fait un choix personnel
après un parcours plutôt triomphal au
masculin comme au féminin
quant aux prétendants à la succession et
ils sont nombreux et parmi eux d'anciens
vainqueurs de la coupe davis où il
reportage de leurs offres avec volets et
dominique merlet
waze là où il ya de la musique on est
sûr que yannick noah n'est pas loin
effectivement le voici en provenance
directe de new york où il vient de
s'installer
noah qui participent à un tournoi
seniors au racing club de france mais
qui vient surtout confirmer qu'il ne
sera plus à la fin de l'année le
capitaine d équipe de france
une décision irrévocable c'est le salut
l'artiste
c'est pas tout à fait content légers les
ventes en uc telon ces décisions encore
une fois que tu es pas facile à pas
depuis que j'ai prise je me sens très
bien je suis très content vous êtes
donc il s'en va le tennis français se
sont évidemment un peu orphelin alors
qui pour lui succéder
curieusement l'intéressé semble s'en
laver les mains ça me regarde pas sont
pas mes oignons et me détache de sa
justement pour du recul par rapport à
tout ça favori néanmoins tous les îles
et guy forget un vrai successeur naturel
que yannick soutien en privé d'emploi du
temps qui est relativement libres
partiellement il ya une réelle volonté
de la part des joueurs de de faire appel
à mes services
la mesure du possible
oui moi je suis intéressé oui mais
forget n'est plus seul
henri leconte et depuis ce matin
officiellement candidat au poste de
capitaine
pourquoi pas mais cela vient brouiller
un peu les cartes en vue d'une fonction
forcément sensible penser a dit je
trouve qu'ils ont une très bonne
solution mais pourquoi pas donc le
essayer de faire quelque chose comme je
devais ensemble faire un peu ce qu'on
est jeunes n'ont aucune expérience il
savait très dur donc ou alors moi je
suis prêt à toute éventualité
alors association affrontements en vue
pour l'instant entre forget et leconte
on rigole encore ensemble mais attention
aux ambitions déclarées théâtre pendant
15 semaines dans le centre de la france
est en ce moment même après ni sur
claise en indre et loire le voyage des
comédiens trois compagnies théâtre se
sont unis grâce à nicolas peskine pour
interpréter shakespeare brèches mais
aussi des oeuvres plus récents et cela
dans tous les lieux possibles des villes
et villages traversés reportage carling
laudrin et christophe vignal a pressé
sur claise les joueurs avaient plutôt
tendance à se ressembler jusqu'au jour
où ils ont débarqué puisqu'il préfère
les comédiens du voyage ces petites
communes un peu oubliés ils arrivent
avec leurs instruments leurs jolis
textes ils s'approprient les lieux
séduisent tout le monde et entraîne tout
un village sur leurs pas maître d'école
un abribus
tout est bon pour y aller de sa tirade
le public est bien sûr un peu timide au
départ mais finalement curieux de voir
ce que ces saltimbanques gourou bien
pouvoir le raconter soit ajouté bhv
c'est quoi ça y est ils se sont pris au
jeu
aussitôt conquis aussitôt emmenés vers
le campement
c'est bien la première fois que leur
domaine que je vois ça a pris bien
plaisir
croyez moi
pour les accueillir il faut de la place
une quarantaine de caravanes des semi
remorques qui se déploie pour former un
vrai théâtre en quinze jours il propose
une douzaine de spectacles à la fois des
pièces classiques d'autres plus
contemporaine du théâtre pour tous les
goûts pour tous les publics
ce que nous avons en face de nous c'est
le monde c'est à dire le notaire
nouvelle école le jeune vieux leriche le
pauvre malade toute la ville est là ce
soir là on jouait au cabaret la noce
chez les petits bourgeois de bertolt
brecht un repas de mariage qui vire au
cauchemar
toute une société qui perd son vernis
sur un ton but renaissent tu vas tu n'as
pas non plus l'ouvrir aux populations je
ne comprends toujours moins d'à priori
car envie qualité
on semble justement beaucoup plus naïve
pour est ce qu'il voit qu un public
averti
pour cette première journée tout le
monde a suivi il n'y avait même pas
assez de places pour le spectacle
cabaret finalement c'est fou comme les
journées passent vite à prilly sur
claise voit la fin de ce journal je
rappelle lapin le principal titre de
cette édition l'ouverture aujourd'hui du
procès de florence rey devant les
assises de paris
bon ça qui est accusé notamment du
meurtre de trois policiers dans ces
assises
son procès devrait durer deux semaines
on peut entrer risque la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité
dans un instant la météo sera présentée
par isabelle martinet du soleil et de la
chaleur pour le week-end et puis un
document dans envoyé spécial johnny
hallyday reportage effectué pendant les
six mois de préparation de son spectacle
du stade de france
toutes les coulisses inédite à zéro
heure 35 florence du propre pour la
dernière édition du journal demain matin
à 7h50 dans les 4 vérités françoise
laborde recevra claude goasguen
vice-président de démocratie libérale
puis à 13h vous retrouverez carole
gaessler rachid arhab et à 20h béatrice
schönberg à lundi bonsoir merci
je vous retrouve danse